no i don't but maybe i should my fifth
novel much to my despair because it was
not the intention i injured more than
one member of my family because they
took some of the portraits to heart
which we're not always kind like I
confess I regret the hurt I don't regret
the book because I like the book and
maybe that makes me a jerk because of
course the book came with the hurt you
couldn't have the book without the
injury so I guess that was a price that
I'm still willing to have paid but you
know anyone else who decides to write
fiction that is so called loosely based
on real people should take it under
advisement that it is a dangerous thing
to do and you know that's a well-told
quote because you you will get into
trouble for everything that you keep the
same and you will get into trouble for
everything that you change no and the
other killer is and this is something
that I remarked on in this article you
can be incredibly complimentary
infection I mean you can you can you can
play too what this real person likes
about themselves for pages and pages but
if you insert a single line that hits a
nerve and and violates what that person
wants to think of themselves that's all
they'll remember that is all they will
remember you know and that's where you
really can't win and these you know
these perceived insults are forever
that's one of the deadly things about
the written word you it's out there
you can't take it back and you know it
is a book that the whole plot is made up
people's professions are made up it
starts out and both parents are dead and
and at writing my parents were alive and
as we speak they are still alive knock
wood they will stay that way as long as
possible so I did I changed all kinds of
things but it didn't make any difference
and you know I have a feeling that with
the benefit of hindsight there might
have been a few lines that I could have
changed you know those single lines I'm
talking about I think they could have
been slightly altered with and made
really no significant artistic sacrifice
and have done less harm and I'm sorry
about that